the White House was thinking about the
next step and its face off with North
Korea a top official in the North is now
promising weekly missile tests that
follows Sunday's launch that failed in a
fiery explosion vice president Mike
Pence flew from South Korea to Japan
overnight he reassured the Japanese
Prime Minister that the United States
will respond to any threat Margot
Brennan is at the White House with the
newest warnings from both sides Margaret
good morning good morning while in Tokyo
vice president pence said that economic
and diplomatic pressure may still
convince North Korea to abandon its
nuclear program but it appears that
leader Kim jong-un is willing to pursue
it at any cost I don't want to Telegraph
what I'm doing or what I'm thinking
president Trump refused to explain his
strategy but in an interview yesterday
he said all of his predecessors had been
outwitted by North Korea's leaders you
look at different things over the years
with President Obama everybody's been
outplayed they've all been outplayed by
this gentleman and we'll see what
happens in Japan today vice president
Mike Pence reassured the US ally that
military action is not the first choice
but it is an option all options are on
the table and there they will remain in
a show of force the USS Carl Vinson
aircraft carrier has been directed to
the Korean Peninsula and will arrive
next week in an effort to push Kim
jong-un to the negotiating table the US
has continued to increase sanctions and
cyber sabotage its nuclear weapons
program mr. Trump is also betting that
China will do for him what it has failed
to do for past US presidents cut off
financial support to destitute Pyongyang
on Monday North Korea's ambassador to
the UN issued a warning it has been
created dangerous situation in which the
summer nuclear war may break out at any
moment on the peninsula a question of
what mr. Trump will do next followed him
to the White House Easter Egg Roll
behave question remains just what that
next move will be a State Department
official told reporters yesterday that
the US will not stand idly by and when
asked about the possibility of us strike
said we will we are committed to
defending our people if necessary all
right Thank You Margaret